weber got another shot at this starting
rotation because he did pitch so well
out of the bullpen you really have to
give him credit
whatever they wanted him to do one time
he puts a six inning stint out of the
bullpen the weird problem with him as a
starter as everybody knows by now is not
throwing enough strikes he's walking a
lot of guys marcelo zuna is coming up
hit in the air and hit well to left
field back toward the green monster and
gone for marcel ozuna
two-run home run and the braves break in
front right away two to nothing
pulled his hands in got the barrel of
the ball and hit it out wow pretty
impressive
a line drive into center a base hit
that's the second hit of the inning and
darno's aboard in front of sizzling hot
austin reilly it swings the first pitch
and hammers that toward deep center that
ball is high off the wall bradley plays
the caro darneau around third is going
to slam on the brakes and scramble back
riley almost hit it out to straight away
center he'll stand and sank him with a
two-out double ian anderson who has an
unbelievable act of his own to follow in
his second big league start yeah last
wednesday truest park
just dazzled gave up one hit opposite
field homer to voigt
two pitches we saw the most was the
fastball and really had that change-up
working kept aaron hicks gardner off
balance
that one belted into right field for a
base hit so verdugo is on with a single
just keeps on hitting
he swings and has another single base
hit into center field
just to the right of the second baseman
camargo
so the red sox have the lead man on for
the second time in three innings down to
second limb aroused grounds out and so
with one away here comes radugo ground
ball another base hit into center field
zooey lynn rounding he scores easily
rudugo now two for two give him 13 rbis
and the red sox trail by one
gets himself in scoring position
he did and he rakes it into right field
here comes verdugo
deval throwing home it's up the line and
the red sox of titans can't bring it
into second rafael devers
green lighted on 3-0 to paid off a 2-2
game
again
well that's a swinging bunt practically
going to let that roll but it dies in
the grass for a base hit so vasquez is
on well that is a beautiful thing
when you when you knock one down there
like that
it's like oh yes
all you're hoping is it doesn't hit the
dirt and roll
and the pitch
swung on this one stays in play for
riley right at the bag he'll glove it
step on the base and end the inning
so anderson pitches around the swinging
bunt hit and the walk
red sox leave two and we go to the six
still tied to two
line right back where it came from and
that's off arius's glove
and marcakus will
stop at second a missile off the bat of
darneau and the braves are in business
with two on and nobody out and hot
hitting austin riley coming up
good speed aboard
and nobody out line right field a base
hit that's going to score one darno
around third is going to be stopped as a
terrific throw by verdogo stops the
bleeding for the moment atlanta takes
the lead riley comes through it's three
to two atlanta now in ciarte the center
fielder has grounded back to the pitcher
and grounded to short stock trying to
limit the damage
chopper off the plate that's going to be
a tough play
close at first and not in time infield
hit for ender and the braves get a
fourth run a baltimore chop for ender in
crt and boston mass and the braves get a
second run of the sixth inning
two good curve balls
he's got him to swing through
and another
he can't hit it keep throwing it and uh
anderson has another strikeout that's
seven
that's a new major league high he struck
out six yankees in his debut
and just like that two outs in the
inning
strike three right down the middle eight
strikeouts for ian anderson and if
that's the swan song boy what a song it
was in his second big league start
i don't know
telling himself to calm down or
something well ozuna was he teamed the
monster in the first inning with a
two-run homer as this one's launched
high in the air deep left field ozuna
has tamed the monster for a second time
a two homer night for ozuna
a solo shot this time and the braves
extend the lead he's in double digits
with home run number 10.
second multi-home run game of the year
broken bat little flare that's going to
drop for a base hit streaking around is
camargo he's going to score standing up
dansby swanson with a broken bad hit
drives home his 21st run and the braves
extend their lead
lined into left center field the hit
streak lives on one run will score
freddie will stop it first on his way to
third is dansby and the braves are
pouring it on it's now 7-2 a 15-game hit
streak for freddie freeman
four straight singles in the eighth
inning and ozuna's up with the two homer
night
high towering fly ball deep center make
it a three homer night wow over the
batter's eye in straight away center
i don't know if i've ever seen a ball go
up there at fenway i was just saying the
same thing up where the cameras are
above the batter's eye
i can't wait for the tail of the tape on
that baby the braves with a 10-2 lead
ozuna with three homers
and six rbis
swinging a high fly ball
hit to left field looking up and that
ball is off the wall
karen's back to marcakus and that'll be
a double for xander bogarts his first
hit coming with one down to the eighth
sox have not scored since the third
inning
he's gonna loft that one in the outfield
for a base hit
bogarts will round and he is in to score
so an rbi for jbj his 12th of the year
and that'll make it 10 to 3.
now bradley picks up his 12th rbi of the
season
on the ground to dansby to the bank for
one to first for two and the braves have
beaten the red sox
10-3 they've won the series in boston
thanks to that man's
historic night his first career three
homer game
first national league player with three
homers in a single game at fenway park
six of atlanta's 10 rbis and atlanta
jeff goes for the sweep tomorrow